i think it's interesting that we
are talking about anxiety and not fear i
think there's a an important distinction
to be drawn
um why is the 20th century or 21st
century an age of anxiety
in the past i think people had a lot
more to be frightened about as thomas
just said you know
early death violent death um
you know the world has become much safer
all the
causes of fear have um or most of them
are no longer part of our everyday lives
and yet
um in place of that we've become more
and more anxious so there seems to be
an inverse correlation between fear and
anxiety
and that strikes me as very interesting
well and even you should put your finger
on on what is the cause of your anxiety
well fear you can identify the cause
right yes that's i mean i mean a lot of
um the modern talk of anxiety of course
comes from martin heidegger
his famous book being in time in which
he analyzes angst
and he says exactly that that when
you're frightened there's something
you're frightened of
you know a wolf or it has an object
whereas when you're anxious
you're not anxious about anything in
particular it's a
sort of free-floating mood which can be
transferred from one thing to another
i'm not quite sure that's accurate
because we are
anxious about certain things i looked in
the
french newspaper yesterday and it was
clear that if we were not going to be
beheaded in the street
we were going to die of covid and if we
didn't die of kobe
we were going to live the rest of our
lives in poverty
so i think actually information and
commentary
information and commentary is but
they're very important in a way this
abundance of
of causes of fear dilutes fear into
anxiety
that's and the anxiety can attach itself
to this or this or this
um so when one cause of anxiety
disappears another immediately
pops up to take its place so but
journalists and
and people thrive on on creating
problems you know
don't nobody says well uh last year the
life expectancy was the highest ever
uh instead i think it does well steven
think it does but it doesn't have any
effect because
we all know that uh fear is much greater
than
optimism so um
so i think the the constant feeding of
of dangers and you can see it even in
small things so that for example
one of the things i've noticed how
traffic jams are so much worse during
term time
because parents are taking their
children to school
in cars whereas during
holiday time they don't and there's no
reason why they should be taking their
children
to schooling cars because the children
could walk well
they're terrified
you